[Musik]
er heißt michel houellebecq und er ist
so etwas wie das enfant terrible der
französischen literatur seine texte
ziehen an und sie stoßen ab je nachdem
und manchmal beides zugleich seinen
romanen titel sind lapidar ausweitung
der kampfzone oder elementarteilchen zur
eben auf deutsch erschienen sein
jüngstes buch karte und gebiet in
frankreich eine literarische sensation
und 2010 mit dem prix goncourt
ausgezeichnet
erster eindruck des buches das enfant
terrible scheint nicht mehr ganz so
terrible mythen zu müssen
juri steiner hat den streitbaren
schriftsteller und landvermesser
houellebecq zum klärenden gespräch
gebeten
sehr geehrter herr weg sie sind erneut
gelesen französische art oder gegenwart
sie werden in frankreich als blutleer
der supermärkte bezeichnet sie hatten
fünf große romane geschrieben die in 40
sprachen übersetzt wurden mit
millionenauflage und ihr neues buch
karte und gebiet setzt einen weiteren
meilenstein in dieser geschichte in
diesem buch erscheinen sie selbst als
figur mit ihrem namen michel houellebecq
und sie werden getötet darf eine
bestialische art und weise zusammen mit
ihrem hund platon in ihrem landhaus wie
lebt es sich eigentlich als toto autor
er besser so früher oder später ist man
sowieso ein toter autor ich habe
feststellen müssen dass ich eine so
öffentliche person geworden bin dass ich
es verdiene in einem buch vor zu kommen
um um sagen wir mal eine facette des
zeitgeistes darzustellen
eigentlich stelle ich im buch gar nicht
viel da ich bin jemand den ein galerist
bittet das vorwort zum
ausstellungskatalog eines künstlers zu
schreiben und zwar weil dessen
potenzielle käufer nicht franzosen sind
also brauchte einen autor der in
genügend sprachen übersetzt wurde
deshalb trete ich zuerst einmal in
erscheinung
es gibt ja die klassische frage fast
dass das leben oder die kunst zu fest
auf das objekt auf das kunstwerk sich
bezieht und zu wenig auf den
künstlerinnen eine ganze grundlegende
frage ist die das leben in die kunst zu
überführen und eigentlich ist ja dieser
mord der an ihnen vollführt wird eine
art übersetzung von ihnen oder von
dieser figur in ein kunstwerk in einen
schlechten jackson pollock das schreiben
sie auch weil ein verrückter
wissenschaftler sie in tranchen schneit
köpft in den tranchen schneidet haben
sie diesen prozess also ins kunstwerk
damit mit diesem fast rituellen mord
vollzogen
ich mag jackson pollocks und manchmal
wenn ich angst zustände aber empfinde
ich das was er malt wirklich als
gemessen
aber ich habe welbeck weniger wegen der
mordszene umgebracht sondern vielmehr
wegen seiner beerdigung die mir gut
gefällt
mir gefällt auch dass er der atheist ist
sich gewissermaßen als vorsichtsmaßnahme
taufen lässt
vor allem aber gefallen mir die wenigen
menschen die ihm auf der straße das
letzte geleit geben und recht fröhlich
sind für eine beerdigung
ich wollte auch meinen grabstein
beschreiben ja ich habe ihn vor allem
wegen der beerdigung szene umgebracht
weniger wegen des mordes dieser
schrecklichen tat sondern vielmehr wegen
der beerdigung die ziemlich fröhlich
geraten ist
haben sie denn jetzt für richtiges leben
ähnliche vorkehrungen getroffen
ich habe mir gesagt wenn ich mal sterbe
kann man es machen wie im buch das
gefiel mir aber vielleicht hätte ich gut
daran es von einem notar beglaubigen zu
lassen
karte und gebiet ja ihr neues buch ist
ganz vieles auf einmal es ist ein
künstler malen ein thriller
eine satire über über frankreich eine
zukunftsvision frankreichs ein loblied
auf die provinz eine
vater-sohn-geschichte ein hunde buch
auch es handelt vom alten vom tod von
sterbehilfe und sie schreiben am schluss
in ihrem dankeswort dass wir uns in
einem fiktiven raum des romans befinden
trotzdem hat es ganz viele
dokumentarische und autobiografische
teile einsprengsel die über sich selbst
hinaus gehen wie wichtig ist diese
autobiografie und das dokumentieren zwei
verschiedene fragen was das
autobiografische betrifft habe ich bei
diesem buch etwas interessantes
beobachtet
auch wenn man sich persönlich als figur
wählt oder vielmehr das bild das andere
von einem haben wird diese figur sehr
bald zu einer romanfigur wie alle
anderen nur um erläutert es ist also
egal wen man als figur nimmt sie wird
sehr bald einmal autonom was meine
dokumentierung anbelangt habe ich den
eindruck dass ich verglichen mit dem
französischen schriftsteller gut dastehe
im vergleich mit amerikanischen autoren
aber weniger gut dokumentiert
wenn ich themen behandelt die ich nicht
gut kenne dokumentiere ich mich für den
roman elementarteilchen habe ich mich
mit physik befasst für die möglichkeit
einer insel habe ich bücher gelesen
ich lese grundsätzen sich am liebsten
bücher plattform habe ich bücher über
tourismus gelesen und eine touristische
rundreise gemacht aber ich habe nicht
viel über das polizei milieu geschrieben
aus nicht so leicht erklärbaren gründen
die polizei beeindruckte mich wohl zu
sehr und das ist eine so fremde welt
dass ich nun für mein neuestes buch zum
ersten mal in meinem leben sehen wollte
wie und wo die polizei arbeitet am pc so
felber alle diese vielen geschichten die
sich zusammenfinden in diesem buch haben
etwas gemeinsam auch mit den anderen
romanen die ich von ihnen gelesen habe
nämlich die frage nach dem glück wie
kann man überhaupt glücklich leben in
einer welt voller misere christes
langeweile übersättigung haben sie
selbst eine antwort auf diese frage nach
dem glück gefunden
[Musik]
es gibt gewisse unmöglichkeiten der
vater von jets zum beispiel ja sein
vater hatte sich in seinem leben einzig
immer die arbeit definiert also in
pension geht ist er am ende auch jet
definiert sich über seine arbeit
aber er hat das glück eine arbeit zu
haben die er bis ans ende ausüben kann
das ist für schriftsteller und auch für
künstler der fall aber nicht für den
chef eines unternehmens
wir menschen die sich nur über ihre
arbeit definieren ist die pensionierung
tödlich deshalb kann er nicht mehr
glücklich sein
das beantwortet die frage zwar nur
teilweise leicht da schon ist eine
schwere frage aber das glück zu reden
etwas anderes was mich so als schweizer
leser sehr interessiert hat ist die
begeisterung fürs landleben und zwar in
einem land wie die wie frankreich das
sehr zentralistisch ist und man das
gefühl hat paris ist alles die provinz
ist nichts und die menschen in ihrem
roman wenn sie nach in die zukunft bis
2020 glaube ich geht gehen wieder zurück
aufs land sie essen wieder frösche
schnecken schweinereien sie wandern sie
restaurieren alte dörfer und ich habe
das gefühl gehabt dass dieses land leben
das sie bestreiten diese utopie sehr gut
zur schweiz passen würde viel besser als
zu frankreich ich kenne die schweiz
nicht genug um das sagen
etwas scheint mir aber sicher zu sein
die modernität und als folge das leben
in der großstadt führen für die
betroffenen gesellschaften in die
sackgasse sei es nur aus demografischen
gründen
wenn ein land sich nicht mehr
reproduzieren kann stirbt
das gilt für praktisch alle
westeuropäischen länder und frankreich
steht diesbezüglich am schlechtesten da
was gründen die für beobachter ein wenig
erstaunlich sind denn tatsächlich gibt
es in frankreich einige sehr
interessante maßnahmen die es eltern
ermöglichen kinder zu haben und
gleichzeitig zu arbeiten
wer aber in der nähe von paris lebt kann
es sich angesichts der preise dort
schlichtweg nicht leisten kinder zu
haben
deshalb gibt es weniger kinder und das
land stirbt
ich glaube also nicht dass man wirklich
die wahl hat wenn man überleben
andererseits ist das internet eine große
hoffnung
ursprünglich wurden städte gebaut um den
ideenaustausch aber auch den
warenaustausch zu fördern mit dem
internet hat die nützlichkeit der städte
im waren- und ideenaustausch abgenommen
[Musik]
und dank internet können die menschen
fern arbeit verrichten zumindest
teilweise und an einem ort leben wo ihr
kinderwunsch realisierbar ist
meiner meinung nach ist das die einzige
überlebenschance für westeuropa euro
andererseits mit dem buch auch
ersichtlich wie sich die internationale
arbeitsaufteilung immer mehr durchsetzt
und dass sich frankreich auf seine
berufung als landwirtschafts- und
tourismus nation zurück besinnen sollte
zwei bereiche in denen das land stark
ist aber es gibt ja jetzt neben diesen
demografischen oder pragmatischen
bewegungen auch etwas was wie eine
ideologie vielleicht dahinter sie
schreiben oder sie haben mal in einem
artikel in für den figaro
geschrieben von den konservativismus als
quelle des fortschritts und man hat das
gefühl dass dieses land leben auch eine
gewisse restaurierung konservativer den
ist und sie hatten eigentlich auch
einmal ein loblied auf routine und
trägheit mit dem konservativ
konservativismus gleichgesetzt
im besagten figaro artikel habe ich
erklärt dass die wissenschaftler in
erster linie eine theorie aufzustellen
kostet sie so viel mühe dass sie diese
nur ändern wenn die tatsachen sie dazu
zwingen dann sind sie zu radikalen
veränderungen bereit
aber sie warten bis es unvermeidbar
geworden ist und dieser widerstand
gegenüber veränderungen ermöglicht den
war und fortschritt man ändert also erst
dann etwas wenn es sich nicht mehr
vermeiden lässt und show und schoß
gegossen toni michels dem ensemble mich
beeindruckt diese vorgehensweise der
wissenschaftler im großen unterschied zu
den politikern beobachtet der
wissenschafter anstatt zu argumentieren
vielleicht experimentiert obwohl im
bereich der menschlichen aktivitäten aus
moralischen gründen nicht alle
experimente möglich sind verblüffend
finde ich hingegen dass die politiker
nur argumentieren daher erscheint ihr
argumentieren oft wie ein leerlauf das
ist in den meisten ländern der welt der
fall
frankreich partner die schweiz ist eher
eine ausnahme denn sie ist ein
demokratisches land soweit ich das
beurteilen
das kann man von frankreich nicht sagen
dort wird die bevölkerung nie
konsultiert
entschuldigen sie ich habe ein wenig den
faden verloren
der erste teil ihrer frage betraf den
konservatismus
nein das ist keine reaktionäre haltung
reaktion er ist jemand der meint ein
rückschritt sei möglich und
wünschenswert
der konservative hingegen denkt wenn
etwas funktioniert und sei es auch nur
halbwegs und mit fehlern thurmann gut
heran dabei zu bleiben
er ist erst zu veränderungen bereit wenn
er weiß dass etwas besseres gefunden
wurde
er bewahrt also in erster linie
theoriekurs haben in diesem video
artikel auch ein bisschen gesagt nicht
ein bisschen sie haben gesagt das
eigentlich am wenigsten bedrohlichkeit
ausgeht von den konservativen
[Musik]
ja das stimmt
wer dinge verändern will wirkt auf
andere immer bedrohlich vielleicht nicht
auf alle optimisten und gutgläubige
finden das sich ja toll aber ich bin
eher vorsichtig und reagiere zuerst
einmal misstrauisch wenn jemand mit
projekten kommt die kühne und globale
veränderungen zu folgen jemand der sagt
wir verändern nichts wie erhöhen einzig
wenn möglich die gewinnmarge ein wenig
ist für mich vertrauenswürdiger was wir
posco führte preview
es gibt ja nicht nur den vorsichtigen
michel houellebecq es gibt es ja auch
den michel houellebecq wir oft in den
medien auftaucht als provokateur oder
agent provokateur jemand sehr sehr hart
aus teilte ehrlich ist der offen ist der
über heikle themen wie sechs
kapitalismus schreibt und also ich
bleibt man dann immer auch bei der
sexualität hängen zuerst einmal und
warum ist eigentlich 6
so wichtig bevor ich auf diese sehr
wichtige frage eingehen möchte ich die
schweizer auf etwas hinweisen dass ihnen
vielleicht nicht bewusst ist meine
ausführungen über den konservatismus
würden in frankreich bereits als
provokation empfunden
das muss man wissen
aber ja die sexualität spielt eine
wichtige rolle
[Musik]
es gibt wenige freunde
so aber freuten sind wichtig und die
sexualität ist die einzige die auch noch
gesund ist
und bei der exzesse nicht schaden kann
oder selbst beim essen
ich bin franzose und esse sehr gerne
aber beim essen sind exzesse sehr
schnell einmal schädlich so viel
sexualität schadet hingegen nicht nehmen
wir den tabak ich bin raucher eine
einzige zigarette ist schädlich das ist
lästig ich sollte besser zu rauchen
aufhören und dafür nur auf die
sexualität setzen sie ist also trotz
allem wie auch immer in meinen büchern
ist sie immerhin mit liebe verbunden
sie ist nicht losgelöst von der liebe
man lebt nicht nur um zu leben
man lebt für gewisse dinge mein leben
mit gewissen menschen zusammen zu sein
[Musik]
und unter diesen menschen sind die
wichtigsten jene mit denen man eine
sexuelle beziehung eingeht
es ist also doch ein wichtiges thema im
leben von männern und frauen
man kann romane schreiben ohne ein wort
über die liebe zu verlieren es gibt
schöne romane ohne liebesgeschichte aber
sie sind selten in den meisten kommt die
liebe vor mit mehr oder weniger präzisen
beschreibung und der sexualität
ich schreibe über die sexualität weil
ich finde dass ich das kann ich habe den
eindruck das resultat ist befriedigend
und entspricht den sexuellen empfinden
viele die natur kann ich weniger gut
beschreiben wirklich in meinen büchern
beschränke ich mich auf ein paar sätze
auf kleine abschnitte aber ich bleibe
nicht lange dabei gewisse dinge klammere
ich aus sexszenen sind schwierig aber
beerdigungen lasse ich mir nicht
entgehen
sie sind meine große stärke
es ist also immer eine mischung
es kommt darauf an was man wichtig
findet und auch ob man es gut
beschreiben kann das spielt eine rolle
ein beispiel bald sagt den ich sehr mag
kann mich entflammen für die veränderung
einer geldsumme durch verschiedene
zwischenhändler und die zinsen die sich
anhäufen
das könnte ich nicht manchmal gerätes
bei balzac auch ein wenig lang aber ich
ging er nicht so weit wie er das
gedränge mir nicht für ihre rippen yoko
habe die sexualität
er taucht bei ihnen jahre auf als etwas
was sie ist ja direkt auch mit dem
kapitalismus in beziehung setzen und sie
schreiben ja auch darüber dass der
ökonomische liberalismus auch einen
sexuellen liberalismus als parallele
existenz mit sich bringt und dass eine
breite verarmung ein paar purismus
breiter bevölkerungsschichten dadurch
entsteht weil es auch menschen gibt die
keinen zugang zur sexualität so der
frühere minister es ist vollkommen
richtig
aber es ist einfacher diese frage anhand
einer figur zu beantworten
michel houellebecq im buch nein ich habe
nicht an ihn gedacht wenn wir darüber
reden da nehmen wir besser ausweitung
der kampfzone
dieses buch beginnt eigentlich nicht als
roman sondern mit einer einzelnen person
die überlegungen zur lage der welt an
stellt der romantik geht eigentlich erst
als dieser auftritt ich war damals sehr
verblüfft über dies sind mehr als 20
jahre her seit ich dieses buch
geschrieben habe
mich beeindruckte das disco trotz seiner
einfachheit ein großes dramatisches
potenzial hat er hatte noch nie sex
möchte mit allen frauen schlafen aber
keine will ihn mit dieser einfachen
tatsache kann man eine berührende und
faszinierende figur schaffen
das hat er mir den wunsch geweckt
weitere romane zu schreiben und es tat
mir leid dass ich dies rang am ende des
buches sterben ließ was gut ist die
figur von tis beantwortet diese frage
genau
wirtschaftlich ist er gut gestellt
sexuell spricht er niemanden an
zudem lebt er in einem land in dem die
prostitution nicht geregelt ist
er hat also nichts das erscheint
vielleicht extrem aber das gibt es
er ist ein mauerblümchen und er will
nicht mit einer prostituierten schlafen
er sucht eine frau die ihn liebt aber
die gibt es nicht
er ist nicht attraktiv genug dieser
roman hat die gemüter erregt weil die
allgemeine diskussion sehr dumm war es
ging darum dass die gesellschaft die
sexualität verbiete und man sie befreien
müssen
[Musik]
nun früher war das sicher einmal wichtig
aber ich habe nie erlebt dass mir die
gesellschaft die sexualität verwertet
werden ich habe einzig gesagt dass man
sex haben kann hänge davon ab ob man
attraktiv ist oder nicht war es das
schien etwas total neues zu sein obwohl
es nur eine beobachtung eines gesunden
menschenverstandes war noch etwas
eine figur habe ich in ausweitung der
kampfzone nicht weiterentwickelt eine
nebenfigur mighty die so etwas wie das
weibliche pendant ist ihr kam ich zu
wenig konturen und ich kam viel später
in karte und gebiet in der figur von
marin wieder auf sie zurück wer seine
sexualität nicht aus lebt kann
tatsächlich psychische probleme bekommen
die man ernst nehmen muss
anders ist es wenn die enthaltsamkeit
gewollt ist
es gibt mönche die sehr glücklich sind
daran zweifle ich keinem moment noch
einmal vielleicht diese bzw
der ökonomie und der sexualität das dass
sie selber ja ein fast ein fan der
porsche sind dass der konsumtempel und
auf der anderen seite eben diese figur
ist es sehr schöne für gut drauf und er
sie gesprochen haben die ja sich eine
welt außerhalb des kapitalismus erträumt
teilen sie diesen zwar um dann jetzt
meine ich auch ökonomisch gesehen
proposition positiver führung
ich habe keine alternative zum
kapitalismus bis heute wurde die einzige
alternative von der bevölkerung
eindeutig zurückgewiesen
ich sage nichts wäre der kapitalismus
ich habe sogar eine gewisse bewunderung
dafür den kater und gebet ist der etwas
ältere kapital ist gleichzeitig erfinder
und unternehmer
er verdient viel geld damit produkte
herzustellen die das leben der menschen
verbessern
das verkörpert steve jobs im buch den
kapitalismus aller will wären den
kapitalismus der leute die an den
fortschritt der technik glauben der
reine finanzkapitalismus ist mir weniger
sympathisch dass man mit geld
investitionen mehr verdienen kann als
mit den produkten eine erfindung finde
ich gefährlich
der kapitalismus muss ein produktions
kapitalismus bleiben
diese produktion so in dieser
wirtschaftskrise zeit hat man gemerkt
wie die staaten die öffentliche hand die
politik versucht den totalen
kapitalismus einzuschränken oder zu
steuern zu regulieren könnte man auch
die sexualität vom staat regulieren
damit es eben weniger um gerechtigkeit
gäbe ist diese frage auf die schweiz
bezogen oder ist sie grundsätzlich
gemeint
das weiß ich nicht ich sage das weil ich
von einem gesetzesvorstoß in der schweiz
gehört habe der vorsieht behinderten die
kosten für den besuch von prostituierten
zurückzuerstatten das empfinde ich als
zu starken eingriffen sex könnte man
vergleichen mit einem mittel zur
stärkung des wohlbefinden und weniger
mit einem medikament ich finde es
deshalb ein wenig übertrieben dass die
krankenkasse so etwas zurück erstatten
soll
aber gesetze welche die prostitution
kriminalisieren finde ich beschämend
etwas das glaube ich nur in schweden der
fall ist
[Musik]
ich denke der staat darf nicht zu direkt
eingreifen
er sollte die prostitution einfach zu
lassen und sicher nicht verbieten
natürlich braucht es einen gesetzlichen
rahmen prostituierte müssen steuern
bezahlen also muss die sache geregelt
sei aber mehr sollte der staat nicht
eingreifen
bei dieser freien wirtschaftlichen
tätigkeit der ökonomie klima der michel
houellebecq in buch lässt sich ja taufen
bevor er stirbt das eine interessante
kleine passage
man weiß nicht genau macht das weil er
ahnt dass nicht mehr lange lebt oder das
ist ein bisschen unvermittelt diese
dieser information die man bekommt woran
glauben sie der echte michel houellebecq
leider bin ich atheist geblieben nach
vergeblichen versuchen mit dem
katholizismus
es ist aber sehr schwierig ohne gott und
ohne hoffnung auf ein jenseits zu leben
ich würde sagen es ist war unmöglich
wenn man an den tod denkt kann man nicht
mehr leben
man muss ihn also vergessen
und jedes mal wenn er sich an uns
erinnert und näher kommt stürzt man ohne
glauben an gott in totale verzweiflung
ich würde daher sehr gerne an gott
glauben
doch das ist mir nicht gelungen
ich denke der houellebecq im buch lässt
sich kaufen
ich weiß nicht vielleicht aus
performative gründen
er hofft die taufe ermögliche ihm an
gott zu glauben
und deshalb bleibt ihm natürlich auch
eine schöne katholische beerdigungsfeier
ja das ist sein glück tatsächlich für
mich sind katholische zeremonien von
einer schönheit die alles übersteigt
[Musik]
ich liebe die messe sehr und besucher
sie manchmal vor
aber das ändert nichts da ich mich
leicht von stimmungen erfassen lasse
kann ich ihn besonders bewegenden
momenten auch fünf minuten lang an gott
glauben kaum bin ich aber wieder draußen
ist es vorbei eine beerdigungszeremonie
für einen toten freund ist gut
die angehörigen sind froh um das
zusammensein
sie sind stärker angesichts des todes
wenn sie zusammenkommen und hinterher
trinken sie etwas im april aber fünf
minuten nach dem gottesdienst ist der
zauber vorbei
der pfarrer sagte der tote werde ewig
leben
aber er ist und bleibt tot ähnlich
empfinde ich die messe alle tun als ob
sie an gott glauben also mache ich es
ihnen nach aber sobald ich die kirche
verlassen glaube ich nicht mehr daran
die realität bricht wieder über mich
herein
[Musik]
ich komme aus einer familie die schon
seit generationen atheistisch ist ich
bin also der beweis dass der wunsch nach
einem gott sehr lange lebt womöglich
sogar nie stirbt das führe müller prof
[Musik]
dieser wunsch überlebt vielleicht zehn
generationen von atheistischen ddr
alltag oft in ihren romanen ist das
schluss etwas was sich auflöst ins
weitergeht
fast wie in so einem jenseits
übergeleitet eine eine ruhe auch
plötzlich ein pferd sind sind dass die
religiösen momente den
in einem artikel las ich einmal eine
sehr schöne formulierung mit der man das
ende meiner romane beschreiben könnte
die vielleicht so etwas wie die phase
des wandelnden phantoms stelle mir vor
dass der betrag der mensch zum phantom
geworden ist weil alles was in seinem
leben zählte verschwunden ist und er
bewegt sich in einem universum das nach
und nach seine konturen verliert man
weiß nicht aber traurig war so froh ist
oder keines von beiden es ist eine phase
des ohnmächtig werden
eine langsame weiß blende um es mit
einem film technischen ausdruck zu
bezeichnen
alles entledigt sich und wird weiß und
in dieser choreographie drin es in der
gesetze im letzten roman zumindest kein
abrupter tod oder kein abrupter schluss
sondern man spürt auch dass sich etwas
wie erschöpft bei jet dem künstler sich
auflöst automatisch über jahrzehnte in
einem prozess der des rückzugs und die
frage eine grundsatzfrage bei künstlern
ist sie haben es verdient dass sein
glück ist wenn man arbeiten kann täglich
und chat kann sie schreiben dass bis zu
seinem letzten tag täglich noch zwei
stunden arbeiten obwohl er krank ist
aber das wissen ob das was er macht auch
wirklich sinn macht löst sich auch auf
houellebecq schreibt am schluss noch
gedichte die man nicht richtig versteht
also auch hier ist eine art von fragen
nach dem sinn des eigenen tuns und das
ist ja bei künstler wirklich eine eine
existenzielle
dieser mann muss so tun als habe das was
man macht einen sinn
obwohl es niemand versteht ich denke der
sinn ist um objekt selbst enthalten
das klingt vielleicht etwas seltsam aus
meinem mund denn ich habe großen erfolg
also verstehen mich entscheiden
trotzdem steckt er sind zuallererst im
objekt selber man tut etwas
weil man es perfekt findet und es den
eigenen intentionen entspricht und es
gefällt ist man sehr zufrieden sind
eines werkes dicht im werk selber die
rezeption ist zweitrangig das sagen alle
autoren
total war sich bewusst dass er nicht
sofort verstanden würde er schrieb also
man wirklich in 100 jahren lesen war es
noch deutlicher
doch bei ihm waren es andere gründe sein
buch war wegen all dem was es enthüllte
nicht publiziert seine erinnerungen ein
louis kartons schrieb er nicht nur im
wissen dass sie nach seinem tod
veröffentlicht werden würden er hatte
außerdem eine liste mit namen von leuten
die vor der publikation tot sein mussten
der sinn liegt also eindeutig im werk
das aus blend also ja das ausblenden
dass künstler sitz im buch houellebecq
der stirbt haben den tod des autors
beschrieben ein dicklicher geprägt wurde
auch von französischen philosophen
hollerbach und als überblendung in einer
anderen bewegung die geburt des lesers
und diese befreiung des kunstwerks führt
uns ein bisschen natürlich zur frage der
der leser die die schockiert auf ihre
bücher reagieren die sich engagiert
fühlen die prozesse mit ihnen anstrengen
die sie auch bewusst vielleicht falsch
lesen wollen
wie wichtig ist diese subversivität
ihrem büro in ihren büchern und wie
wirksam ist sie zuerst einmal darf man
den einfluss der medien nicht
überbewerten
da ich in frankreich berühmt bin habe
ich oft kontakt mit meinen lesern und
sie wissen meistens nicht dass ich ein
subversiver autor bin
sie haben nichts über mich gelesen oder
gesehen sie kennen nur mein buch dass
dem tatsächlich die meisten meiner leser
wissen nicht dass man mich für subversiv
und provokativ hält der einfluss der
medien ist also weniger stark als man
meinen könnte
was die angriffe betrifft sind sie bei
jedem buch anders bei elementarteilchen
schockierte ich viele leser durch
heftige zeitsprünge wozu ich damals lust
hat celik die rote karte und gebiet
hingegen versuchte ich alles zu glätten
und den leser einzuwickeln er soll
keinen schock erleiden sondern sich
führen und ein wenig hypnotisieren
lassen
doch es ist viel schwieriger diesen
sprachfluss zu erreichen
[Musik]
etwas hat mir beim schreiben dieses
romans sehr gut getan
ich liebe joseph conrads er unter
anderem weil ich seinen äußerst
harmonischen und flüssigen stil
bewundern deshalb tat es mir gut in
einem biographischen hinweis zu lesen
dass er einen schrecklichen
nervenzusammenbruch erlitten hatte dh so
einen flüssigen stil zu erlangen
bedeutet harte arbeit die an die werfen
geht nicht der sprachfluss ist das
natürliche sondern der schock es ist
also gesünder wie dostojewski und nicht
wie joseph conrads sie haben in einem
interview gesagt dass es offensichtlich
mehr provoziert über sechs tourismus zu
schreiben als über die obszönitäten des
kunstmarktes war wie sie es jetzt machen
also ist auch die wahl der themen
natürlich entscheidend über die
aktivitäten des kunstmarktes sage ich
wenig ich beschränke mich auf die
aussage des jet unglaublich hoch im kurs
steht
ähnlich wie künstler die noch mehr
verdienen als er und alles was er
darüber denkt ist dass es keinen sinn
macht ist also nichts dazu zu sagen gibt
zu diesem hohen kurswert kommt wird im
buch nicht gesagt und zwar weil ich
diese welt nicht gut kenne der
presseattaché spielt sicher eine rolle
weil er wichtige sammler an die
ausstellung bringt aber wie er es
schafft diese wichtigen leute zu
überzeugen die ausstellung zu besuchen
reiße ich nicht hätte ich ein buch über
das literatur geschrieben wäre ich
besser dokumentiert gewesen über den
kunstmarkt weiß ich weniger
aber mein buch ist keine satire und den
ich beschreibe die detail ist der
wertschöpfung nicht
[Musik]
tatsächlich ist der sextourismus
detaillierter beschrieben die darauf
folgte jets und das viele geld das dann
kommt lässt sich ja relativ storch und
und unberührt es gibt ihm aber freiheit
da eine unglaubliche freiheit sein leben
zu gestalten sein umfeld zu gestalten
er wird wirklich zu einem bauherrn auch
macht sich ein eigenes gebiet für sich
alleine
geht ihnen das ähnlich mit ihrer eigenen
materiellen freiheit nein bei mir ist
das momentan nicht aber es entspricht
eigentlich meiner natur
ich habe mich dem angenähert die figur
von jet ist mitte noch näher als die von
der wunsch wieder im elternhaus zu leben
die einzige charakteristik von welbeck
im buch trifft auf mich weniger zu aber
eine mauer zu bauen und die vegetation
wachsen zu lassen das gefiel mir sehr
sie haben ja auch eine grandiose
schilderung wie man gute kunst macht
also die die letzten 20 jahre
die service von chat ist der eine
kunstproduktion wo man sagen würde jetzt
kommen viele junge künstler die genau
das produzieren was sicher beschreiben
hatten sie nie das verlangen gespürt
kunst zu machen
bildende kunst
das habe ich gemacht
die verschiedenen schaffensphasen von
jet zuerst die fotos von eisenwaren dann
die fotos von straßenkarten und dann
seine letzte phase mit videoaufnahmen
der vegetation diese drei dinge würde
ich gerne machen
stattdessen habe ich sie beschrieben
tolle chance gefreut weil unschuldige
für reese dekrete
das einzige was mich nicht persönlich
betrifft ist die phase in der jet
wichtige leute portativ ich kann nicht
malen und ich müsste enorm viel lernen
dafür bin ich ein wenig zu faul aber ich
fotografiere gerne das mache ich schon
lange und es gelingt mir gut verrühren
wir jedoch in diesem buch beschreibe ich
ein wenig was ich täte wenn ich künstler
wäre ich höre sie bedauert ist aber sie
werden es nicht umsetzen ist doch kein
galerist gekommen wird ihnen nun ein
vielleicht die videoaufnahmen vom wind
herunter geschlagene erste damit könnte
ich stunden verbringen damit mache ich
vielleicht mal was aber etwas habe ich
erfunden
ich kenne keine software für
mehrfachbelichtungen ich weiß es nicht
ich habe nicht wirklich recherchiert
doch ich habe danach gesucht aber nichts
gefunden
auch den programmentwickler von illinois
habe ich erfunden den gibt es nicht aber
die technik ist eine alte also seine
agenda der stummfilmzeit diese
überblendung methode und sie selbst
hatten ja film studiert und ich habe
einen film realisiert
das war ein film mit schauspieler da
sind die produktionsbedingungen mühsamer
jetzt hingegen ist allein mit seiner
kleinen videokamera das kino tut sich
schwerer mit der kunst
das würde jetzt zu weit führen als
regisseur hat man probleme die mehr oder
weniger gut überwindbar sind
während bei dem was er tut niemandem
verpflichtet ist keine verpflichtungen
zu haben ist sicher besser für die
entstehung eines künstlers als sie ihren
film heraus gegeben habe nachdem sie ein
interview gegeben und man hat die sie
gefragt dass die negative reaktion auf
ihre bücher in frankreich und italien
negativ und setzte sich vielleicht auf
ihren film übertragen könnten und sie
haben gesagt dass sie tatsächlich das
befürchten würden hat sich das
eingestellt werden sie als regisseur
ebenso vehement abgelehnt in frankreich
noch viel mehr
doch das hat der gute folgen denn die
leute wollten den film sehen aber als
regisseur bin ich verletzlich was meine
bücher betrifft habe ich zumindest in
frankreich genügend leser also hat die
negative kritik einen einfach die leute
kaufen meine bücher trotzdem denn sie
lesen die kritiker nicht
dass ich als filmemacher unbekannt war
hätte meinen film vernichten können
durch die hartnäckigkeit mit der die
gleichen leute mich zerreißen
denn die schnittmenge unter literatur
und filmkritikern ist groß ich hatte
also grund zur sorge
und können sie sich eigentlich erklären
dass sie so viele feinde haben ja aber
leider ist die antwort enttäuschend ich
sage es trotzdem ist liegt daran dass
ich keine machtposition habe was ein
fehler ist
ich hätte mich darum bemühen müssen jury
mitglied des wichtigen literaturpreises
werden die buchreihe eines verlages
leiten oder sogar regelmäßig kritiken in
einer wichtigen zeitung schreiben ich
hätte trotzdem viele feinde und kritiker
die sich über mich aufregen aber sie
würden es nicht wagen etwas gegen mich
zu unternehmen weil es
vergeltungsmaßnahmen gebe aber in einer
schwachen position kann ich keine
vergeltung üben
ich bin also ein leichtes ziel ich
belege etwas in frankreich habe ich
anders als viele meiner kollegen
zahlreiche leser logisch sind sie
neidisch auf mich
das ist unvermeidbar angesichts meiner
situation wenn man also neider hat und
annehmen muss dass man verraten wird
muss man wacht positionen bekleiden um
sich dagegen zu wappnen und dann wagt
keiner etwas zu sagen wenn viel zeit und
viel hass da ist und keiner macht
position gibt es viel gewalt das liegt
in der natur der sache
sie werden die strecke ja auch nicht
ändern und in diese machtpositionen
einsteigen
doch vielleicht schon das finde ich eine
gute idee
ich habe mir nie die zeit dafür genommen
aber ich bin überzeugt dass ich es tun
sollte das hat ja auch ein bisschen
vielleicht sich schon jetzt aufgegleist
sie haben mit ihrem letzten buch den
wichtigsten französischen literaturpreis
prix goncourt 2010 gewonnen nachdem es
ja auch polemiken gab sie haben gesagt
dass sie nicht bekommen hätten frieren
sie die jury nicht hätten bestechen
können und so weiter und jetzt haben
sind trotzdem bekommen und haben das als
win win situation beschrieben
ja aber die taktik seines verlags
flammarion ist es die jurymitglieder
nicht zu bezahlen
[Musik]
das ist eine mutige haltung
deshalb stellt er seit seinen anfängen
nur etwa alle 30 jahre einen preisträger
[Musik]
wenn man nicht korrupt ist hat man
weniger oft erfolg das zeigt sich der
geschichte des verlags flammarion hatte
30 jahre lang einen preisträger aber
viele dachten ich hätte der preis längst
verdient also bekam ich passe
das ist doch wichtig denn der preis ist
eine kleine französische tradition wie
der puza lenovo und andere nationale
riten da gehört auch der prix goncourt
dazu leute die mieter kaufen kaufen dem
prix goncourt um ihn weiter zu schenken
oder selber zu lesen
auch ich habe ihn manchmal gekauft es
gab eine zeit da lass ich vor allem
klassiker darunter auch krimis und
science fiction aber die zeitgenössische
literatur meines landes kannte ich nicht
und wegen des prix goncourt habe ich
eine kleine recherche gemacht und
geschaut was es gibt
denn die franzosen lesen und sie werden
weiterhin lesen
die literatur ist wichtig für sie das
ist eine der spannenden seiten dieses
landes umgedrehter schon wenn man die
fünf großen romane nimmt die ausweitung
der kampfzone
die elementarteilchen plattform
möglichkeit einer insel und jetzt die
karte und gebiet welchen dieser romane
hätten sie den rekord gegeben
die antwort fällt mir ein wenig schwer
denn ich habe mich nicht mit der
konkurrenz befasst und präzis antworten
zu können hätte ich den roman lesen
müssen der den preis in jenem jahr
gewonnen hat und die bücher die sich
darum bewerben
das habe ich nur bei elementarteilchen
getan und da war mein buch besser
problemlos und mit abstand die anderen
jahre weiß ich es nicht bei
elementarteilchen war es eindeutig aber
gut was soll's das ist nicht wichtig es
war gut für alle
für den verlag für mich und die tatsache
dass ich den kriegen kur nicht bekam war
zur wiederholungs komik geworden also
waren alle ein wenig erleichtert
erledigt problem gelöst aktives lassen
beck ich gratuliere ihnen nochmals für
diesen preis der prix goncourt und
bedanke mich sehr herzlich für dieses
hochinteressante gespräch vielen dank
ihm wurde ich danke ihnen dass ich
rauchen durfte das erlebe ich selten
[Musik]
michelle houellebecq im einstündigen
gespräch das sehen sie auf unserer
website oder auf dvd noch mal bestellen
können sie wie immer unter schweizer
radio fernsehen redaktions sternstunden
80 52 zürich ihre e mail erreichte uns
unterstellen kopien hat srf punkt ch
nächste woche unterhält sich an dieser
stelle norbert bischoff berger mit dem
philosophen gernot böhme über diese
aktuelle frage haben wir die technik
noch im griff
die frage stellt sich generell was haben
wir überhaupt im griff haben wir zum
beispiel den kapitalismus unter
kontrolle
das fragen wir uns auch in unserem film
gleich in der sternstunde kunst gilt er
noch der amerikanische traum und was ist
der mensch ohne besitz ein künstler oder
eine künstlerin und setzen an zum
angriff auf dem kapitalismus jetzt aber
erst noch kurz zu frischfilm zur
auflockerung zwischendurch zur anregung
schauen sie doch auch mal nach auf
unserer website dort finden sie alles
was es braucht um aktiv mitzumachen und
um hier jetzt gesendet zu werden
[Musik]
es war nicht in bester form
eine tankstelle
gestellt
[Musik]
jetzt wagen zurück
so sind los
das feld wurde
[Musik]
ein stehen
wenn sie hier
wie sind sie
[Musik]
im besten fall finden
bei der migros kasse
[Musik]
angezeigt sei
ich bin ich jung
komplett
genau
fechten
[Musik]
einstieg
wenn zu leben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber nicht irgendwie jetzt wieder normal
[Musik]
zwar bin ich kaum mehr biss
haben spaß gemeint
[Musik]
ich kann lebenswert
aber nicht
verschlafen
[Musik]
mit dem lebens werden sie stützen
der schweiz
[Musik]
jan o